i know better what they want i will go
and build something without talking to
them
right that is not the right strategy and
will not work
[Music]
elon frank so good to have you here
thank you for joining me
thank you so much great to be here we're
going to have so much fun over these
next 20 minutes because this is
hugely relevant to what's happening
today vice president of product
at slack a tool that i believe
everybody watching this obviously uses
and and slowly conquering the world
but we're going to have an amazing
conversation about enterprise software
you have had 20 years of experience in
the space in leadership positions and
most recently now it's slack and
one of the things that we talked about
was that a unifying line throughout this
journey of yours
is the fact that you're passionate about
collaborative software is that an
accident or or is that intentional
uh it was not an accident enterprise
software
is an accident i accidentally ended up
in enterprise software
uh because my my cousin was a venture
uh capitalist back in the early days and
pointed me to a startup that he invested
in that happened to be in the enterprise
space
and that was my initial journey in
silicon valley back in 1997
and uh that's that's what started
enterprise software for me but
um but collaboration once i found
collaboration
um i really found a group um and a
passion
and i've been been pretty much there
ever since okay
but that's well so so take me back you
know to the beginning of your journey
you're just starting out you're you're
starting your path
as you're entering you know enterprise
software what are some of the
sort of the things that looking back you
would tell yourself back then some of
the earned secrets
along the way we're back we're back in
business the same place
what are the earned secrets that you've
over these 20 years if you go back 20
years
what would you tell a young elon uh with
regards to
enterprise software um it's really
important to
focus on the end users this is something
that we didn't know 20 years ago it's
maybe
a little bit more obvious now but that's
something that's that's
critically important um i think what's
more relevant now which is interesting
is that everyone seems to know that you
know enterprise software also has to be
designed well
and you know adoption metrics have to be
taken into consideration
um but we have seemed to forget the fact
that
enterprise software still has something
different from
consumer which is enterprise software
has a user and a chooser
and it is important the chooser is the
the person who makes the budget
decisions person who makes the buying
decisions
um and it's important to consider them
in product management just as much as
the end user
why is that so in my mind this is
i have a sales cycle i go to the
enterprise i pitch to
the director who has the the authority
to sign off on a hundred thousand dollar
you know license
and but the users are the team players
who are at the end are the ones you know
running around and using my software for
whatever they're doing
right so the the dynamic is
that this day um software enterprise
software
is more coming up uh sorry from the
bottom up
right then top down so rather than cio
making a decision and saying everyone's
going to use this
enterprise software is actually being
found
by those ics those individual
contributors that have the jobs
and they want to be more productive at
work they're looking for tools to make
them more productive at work
so that's why it's important to focus on
the end user
um but a lot of and on a lot of
enterprise software companies
um of course like slack are are doing so
right but it's important at the same
time one of the things that people maybe
don't realize about slack
is that we we focus equally on the the
top down what is the
what is it going to be important for the
enterprise buyer and for slacking for
productivity tools specifically
that is productivity and innovation what
are the tools that are going to help
my employees transform themselves to be
more productive to be more innovative
so just going back to that going back to
that now because it's fascinating to me
what you're saying is that
there has been a trend changing that if
previously you go to the ico of the
company they
and your your the cio and you go and you
pitch a product
and you get them to buy into it and then
from top down they disseminated into
their thousand employers so today
you're going after you after the the
team players
and if they love your product they'll
start adopting it throughout the
organization
until there's no point but to actually
you know get it get it
custom for the organization right that's
right okay and then it go
it bubbles up into the cio the cio sees
it as known maybe
as shadow i.t at this point okay now you
want to you know
you as an enterprise software company
want to sell to the cio
this is when the cio is going to look
for different things
their requirements are very very
different from the end users
certainly they want their end users to
be productive but they also have to look
after
beyond cost they have to look after
compliance secure security
and performance those are the things
that really matter to them
um when they're when they're shopping
for software so you have to you have to
make sure that your product
also addresses these needs fascinating
so it sounds to me like you're actually
like you're almost developing
two products because even you know with
let's look at you know slack is a
collab collaboration tool on one hand
you have the end user which is myself i
love sharing my files i love all the
marketplace with integrations my life is
nothing like it was five years ago if i
had slack in high school my high school
would look extremely different than it
does now
because now it's incred it's really it's
incredible i'll just say that it's
incredible
but you know there's all of this in
compliance and security that i'm not
even aware of
for example i work at hippo and you know
i don't really know
what security goes behind the scenes to
make sure that the data that i pass
along
is secured but i'm sure that my cio
knows it very well right
exactly that that's incredible that's
exactly right and
early on in slack we actually did that
we actually and i um i've spoken to many
enterprise software companies
that are starting up and given this
advice is that early on we actually
separated out product management into
self-service
and into enterprise and the self-service
part of product management really focus
on metrics like adoption um usage of
different app you know features um nps
and satisfaction of end users uh the
love of the
of the product and all that right um in
the enterprise side the side that i led
focus exclusively on you know making
sure that new industries new geographies
can actually obtain this
software uh each one has a different set
of compliance requirements security
requirements administration requirements
um so that's how we we looked at the
market in a very different lens
balira ilan your colleague has the
luxury of having data from millions of
users
getting you know aggregating getting nps
scores through logic through the usage
you're coming in and you have a handful
of you know large customers that you're
you're trying to get information from
how do you get an nps score
from those individuals who are who are
buying the software
because you know what every time they
every product class that i ever taught
they told us
your customers don't know what they want
ask them what they need right
so so how do you go about that because
your matrix is
is their satisfaction yeah that's right
so
um by the way the phrase that you just
quoted
has as many times been uh misconstrued
and
especially recently and i want to make
sure
that um people listening to this that
are starting enterprise software
companies
um understand that yes that is true that
customers don't necessarily know the
solution they will
ask for something that sounds like this
solution um but what you need to do
as a good pm is to bring them back to
the problem state the problem and then
your job is to come up with a solution
but a lot of people
misinterpret that statement that you've
had to the customers don't know what
they want i know better what they want
i will go and build something without
talking to them right that is not the
right strategy
and will not work um so the answer to
your question it's a really good
question
with enterprise software it's different
you can't do
a broad you know surveys quant work is
not going to really work because you
just don't have that many data points
exactly but you can certainly go and
talk to people
so the first thing that i recommend for
enterprise software company
uh product managers to do is to set up a
cab a customer
advisory board um bring in your you know
top 20 customers meet with them on a
regular basis once every quarter once
every six months whatever makes sense
for you
present to them your what we do with our
cavs
and what we've done since you know
really four years ago when i joined
slack wow
is um we we meet regularly we present
the roadmap
and get their feedback on what we uh
have show
are showing we have special sections the
next section of the
of the cab it's a one day session
usually um the next section is really to
talk about
three different drill down areas areas
that we're planning on invest
in um recently arvina in the near future
right we really want to get their their
input on so drill downs into specifics
and then the last section is really for
them to talk to us
and hear their feedback and to talk to
one another so the best part of the
of that day a lot of times is just
having them
talk to us and again to each other about
things that are working things that are
not working things that they've tried
um and learning from one another and we
learn from them as well
that is so cool do they one of the best
parts of the day all right are these
pro users in the sense that do they love
slack
or do they is that something that's
common among all of them or are some of
them a little bit more hesitant
so in this case these are all people we
i
that's not a criteria that i use it's
not a limited test that i use
okay getting people on the cab or not
they happen to mostly love slack because
they are responsible for rolling it out
right there um
in their organization one thing that is
important to remember in enterprise
software
is that those admins they're your
champions
right those admins the people that are
are working with your software and
managing your software
they've stayed they've um you know
they've stayed their career
on the success of your product because
that's their career
um and so it's important to listen to
them
um it's important to treat them well and
so they do mostly love slack they do
they are mostly
that makes i mean yeah i mean obviously
the more they like what i yeah
i don't i don't ask that question how
what happens when there's a clash
there's a clash because you have a you
have a road map for enterprise
your colleague has a roadmap for the
self-serve
there's a finite resources as in any
organization
and now you have to make some decisions
how do you quantify the impact
of these two fields which are connected
but disconnected
yeah a lot of it is um
art more than science um especially when
you're talking about
enterprise to enterprise you know
security to admin is pretty easy
right you just look at the tam or the
revenue
impacted or the pipeline that's blocked
based on the features we have reports
that show us exactly how much pipeline
is associated with
you know these big security features or
big administration features
that's easy on the retail side it's also
pretty easy because the numbers the
metrics you know tell you where to
invest
um you know we have a lot of experiments
so we run there and see which one
um you know proves to be better
enterprise to
to retail is a little bit more difficult
and for that what we've done is
we have company priorities um
there are always always somehow there
are three
but there are three company priorities
and your
your initiative similar to a company
pitching to a vc
um we pitch internally wow it has to
align to one of these three initiatives
um and if you know if it does then
that's
you know those are the teams that they
get the resources for the year so
so cool i'm already i'm so upset i'm so
upset that we
were more than halfway through because
there's i'm every question that you
answer i have 10 more questions that i
want to ask
i'll try to keep them short no no no no
no this has been perfect please don't
uh elon you know looking back now or
actually looking forward
you know we can't avoid the fact that
we're you know in the global pandemic
and the world has changed
forever and our workforce has changed
forever
and you know i love your take on where
are we headed in terms of club
collaborative tools productivity as the
world is shifting more and more towards
remote collaboration
and con you know either slack or off
slack
how do you perceive our collaborative
nature digitally as the years are going
to go forward
yeah well so certain this we're not
going to go back
to whatever normal was yeah um
i do think that the office is not a
thing of the past um we will have
offices again we will all be in offices
it will be slightly different i think
we've all realized that people can
actually just be
just as productive at home it's not more
productive
minus minus taking care of kids and all
that but
we'll go to a world where you know kids
are at school and and parents can do
work
um but uh but i think that the the thing
that
is um the trend that we've seen and this
has happened before kobe by the way is
that
responsibility and authority to uh for
decision making
is brought down the um the org chart
right it used to be that decisions went
up
um and they were made at the top um and
then those
those orders came down um but that's
it's almost reversed decisions are being
made in teams
and what's important for executives is
now to understand all the decisions that
are being made
so they can better align and and guide
the team
that is so cool that's a healthy thing
that's good for large organizations to
function that way and i see
in my work with organizations that are
transforming themselves
that more and more of them are working
to that but i think that that is
that kind of reverse information flow is
a new area that's going to be explored
with tools
i don't think that that's an area that
really has been explored
with enterprise software that is so so
cool okay now you're you know 20 years
later you're still an enterprise
software collab
collaborative tools productivity tools
why are you going where are you going to
go into your 21st year i mean what what
make what what does it do for you that
you're in this you know unique
space and in your unique position yeah
i'll tell you and i i don't mean to
bring this back to slack we can talk
about other things but
um but specifically you know four years
ago when i joined slack and i went and
visited my my first customer
um and it was it's a large bank
um you know in the east coast uh and i
met with an employee there
and she told me i love my job
more because i use slack not i love
slack
um which would also be great to hear and
i hear that a lot but but i love my job
you know i'm here nine to five i enjoy
what i do day to day more
because of this tool i'm happier here
when you can have that kind of effect on
most of the waking hours of a person um
you know
they their time away from their family
um that kind of
that that is rewarding um that's a
mission that that i'm
happy to get behind and um is just one
example of companies that are doing
things like that making people's
um you know lives easier and better at
work
and are you is it more in the fact that
you're more curious about enterprise
software that you're just you decided to
focus on that space
or do you see yourself ever shifting to
the self-serve
i i get it i get enterprise software
okay
you know i don't get consumer software
um you know you build something and then
either someone likes it like
you need a 14 year old to like your
product and then all of a sudden
you know other people like it i don't
get that world um
you know i uh i definitely get
enterprise software
i love it i love it okay elon you know
give me you know the now
the broad picture of of collaborative
tools are we all moving more to
real-time communication multiple
integrations
because it seems to me you know that it
seems obvious this is where we're headed
is it more that we're going to see
greater productivity
with using these tools or are we going
to see more
happiness levels or more satisfaction
because i feel pretty productive right
now i have to say i have you know
about a dozen slack channels from you
know like 10 different
segments and and like work spaces and
you know i feel pretty productive and
i'm wondering whether there's now the
aim is to increase my productivity or
increase my happiness level
yeah i think that both go hand in hand
by the way
um i i think that uh people
can be both productive and and happy and
i think a lot of times they actually
uh complement each other so right if i'm
able to be more productive
i'm able to be you know get more
satisfaction out of my out of my job
um so so i wouldn't think of happiness
as as like
just socializing at work or happiness as
right there's happiness from from doing
the work itself
um i think that as far as where we're
going
i let me first take a quick second i
can't ever imagine going back to email
i mean i can't ever imagine in fact i
would use this
as a as definitely a show stopper in
any future company i go to wow
i couldn't imagine coming in the morning
and opening up an inbox
and sorting through 100 or 200
emails like i used to it just seems
so counterproductive um to have my
information sorted by someone else based
on
what subject they wrote and where they
you know
when they sent the message um with slack
and channels
i i dictate you know where i work and
what's important to me i'm subscribing
to the channels that are most important
hundred percent you have it's it's a
different type of control of my day it's
just
it's so backwards for me to think about
email right now
percent as far as where we're going in
the future
i think that there's no question you can
see this with with slack you can see
teams of course you know they copied us
but whatever um
you know it's um you can see the
channel-based communication this this
love this type of subscribing to the
project
and the the topics that i care about um
is the
wave of the future by the way email is
not different as far as the information
that i carry
right email also had topics right every
everything that you did in email was a
topic you were hiring someone you were
working on a project and when you had
multiple ccs you had a channel you had a
exactly right it just was it just was
disorganized it was just organized
you know chronologically based on when
people sent you messages
it just isn't organized well so so slack
is not like
this is new type of work it's just now
organizing your work based on topics
and one of the actually really inspiring
things that i've experienced recently
is using superhuman as an email client
because they managed to
to to reduce the formality of the email
up until now i felt an email i felt
this grave responsibility like it's so
formal
dear sir no no sincere michael i'm not
with superhuman the way that they did it
the chat based
same thing with slack when my manager
here at hippo slacks me
i don't i feel the informality it feels
like an ongoing conversation with the
same content that i would
that i would otherwise get in an email
it makes me respond faster it makes me
more confident
all of a sudden i use emojis in my
messages i love using emojis
it sounds like a joke but it's a serious
thing it makes everything a little
it makes everything more fun yeah yeah i
agree and
you know and more productive um we use
emojis by the way
for productivity so when someone um
wants my attention in a channel they put
a file or something like that
i will use the eyes emoji to say that
i'm looking at it
like calm down i'm looking at it you
know i didn't miss your message
um and then when i'm done i put a green
check box emoji saying it's done you
know i finished my assignment whatever
it is and
that way they know okay this is done i'm
starting to i'm starting to employ that
with with with the team that i'm on
right here
elan this was so thank you for your time
thank you for the generosity this is so
great i know how busy you are
before we leave i need three words that
you would use to describe yourself
uh okay three words um uh can i get
so one i mean there's one word however
however we want to do this
there's one word that actually means
like all three together
let's do it which is kibbutznik i mean i
i
i grew up uh in ed uh and
you know moved to minnesota at age 10
but
um you know the hard working uh you know
collaborative
and humble are things that i aspire to
be
in in my job and i learned those all
before the age of 10.
wow well kibbutz nick said it all you
gave me the three words anyways
afterwards i love it
thank you very very much we we didn't
even mention the whole about j ventures
and working together and i've been
it's been such a pleasure doing some due
diligence with you and i've been
learning a lot from you and everybody
else but
but thank you for thank you for your
time for this and for the fun
and and i look forward to maintaining
this relationship thank you
my pleasure thank you take care bye